Edgar Allan
Poe is probably best known for his raven that
squawks “Nevermore,” but he’s also one
of the first American short story writers
and is often credited with being the “inventor”
of detective fiction.
He also contributed heavily to the genre of
science fiction.
Not only that, but he was one of the first
American writers to earn a living from his
writing alone.
What’s not as well-known about the man is
that Poe had a somewhat turbulent stint in
the military.
The trouble began when Poe enrolled in a course
at the University of Virginia.
His foster father gave him a $100 (about $2,000
today) to cover living expenses for the year.
Any university student today can tell you
that university fees add up—the courses,
the books, endless ramen feasts and printing
charges.
Well, it’s likely Poe didn’t have the
latter two, but with other college expenses
and his gambling habit, he nevertheless quickly
fell into debt.
In the end, he quit university after a year
and moved to Boston.
There, he tried to survive on odd jobs but
needed a form of steady income, so he enlisted
in the army in 1827.
He used the name “Edgar Allan Perry” and
said he was twenty-two years old, even though
he was just eighteen.
Due to the debts he had accumulated in college,
a warrant had been issued for his arrest and
he wasn’t keen on making it easy for the
authorities to find him.
First serving at Fort Independence in Boston,
he was eventually moved to Fort Monroe in
Virginia.
Likely Poe didn’t care where he was, as
long as he continued to get his $5 per month
(about $100 today) from the military.
At first, it appeared that Poe would excel
in the army.
He thrived and was eventually promoted to
sergeant major for artillery, which was the
highest rank achievable by a non-commissioned
individual.
Still, Poe disliked army life.
Only two years into his five-year commitment,
he explained his situation and asked for an
early discharge.
Lieutenant Howard, his commanding officer,
agreed to allow him to leave the army before
his time was up on one condition: he make
amends with his foster father, with whom he’d
always had a shaky relationship.
Poe’s foster father wasn’t amenable to
making amends at first, but a series of unfortunate
events resulted in the death of Poe’s foster
mother and a softening of attitudes between
the two men.
After finding a replacement to finish his
enlisted term, Poe was honourably discharged
in 1829.
He didn’t end his military career there,
however.
Soon after his discharge, Poe enrolled in
West Point and matriculated as a cadet in
1830.
Just as he had in the army, Poe proved a diligent
pupil, great with math and languages and well-suited
to Academy life.
Poe’s time at the academy was financed by
his foster father, John, meaning that Poe
needed his foster father’s permission in
order to drop out if he wanted to.
Unfortunately, Poe’s relationship with his
foster father was soon on the rocks again
after John married his second wife, Louisa
Patterson.
Soon after the marriage, Poe learned that
John had fathered illegitimate children with
another woman—one of them twenty years his
junior.
It led to a row between the two, and Poe received
a letter saying that his foster father wanted
no further communication with him.
An angry Poe sent a letter to his foster father
letting him know about everything that had
infuriated him over the years, and demanding
that he let Poe drop out of West Point.
The letter ended with the ominous declaration
that if he wasn’t allowed to leave gracefully,
he’d get himself kicked out.
With no response from John, Poe set out to
make good on his threat.
The prestigious student fell from grace, racking
up an impressive 44 offenses and 106 demerits
in one term alone, followed by 66 offenses
in one month the next term.
He was court-martialed and tried at the beginning
of February for “gross neglect of duty.”
His various offenses included being absent
from class parades, guard mounting, and church
parades.
He also didn’t show up for academic classes,
and refused to obey officer’s orders.
There was a rumour that he once turned up
to drills in a belt and nothing else, but
there’s nothing in his official record to
corroborate this.
Interesting though such a stunt would have
been, Poe’s preferred method of mayhem was
not showing up to anything at all.
Poe was, of course, found guilty of all charges
and kicked out of West Point.
He headed off to New York to pursue writing,
but not before he’d gotten a little something
extra out of the military first.
He convinced over 100 cadets to donate money
to fund the release of a new volume of poems,
titled simply Poems.
The book was dedicated to his fellow cadets.